hi how are you doing i'm going to teach
you how to make sense of feynman
diagrams
know what all the squiggly lines mean
and work out if they're representing a
valid particle interaction or
if they're defying the laws of physics
[Music]
a fireman diagram is a picture of what
happens when particles interact with
each other
particles go in one end come out the
other and some
stuff happens in the middle and to make
sense of foam and diagrams you need to
know
three things what all the lines and
arrows mean
what all the particles in the standard
model are as well as their special
properties like
charge and spin what the overall rules
are
these are called conservation rules but
you could call them
in-out rules as in you can't get out a
different amount than what you put in
here's a feynman diagram the lines
represent different particles which are
traveling through space and time which
are represented by these
axes note that with one dimension of
space we're losing some spatial
information here so these really are
schematics
of what a particle interaction looks
like rather than an accurate depiction
of our four-dimensional reality
here's an example with a little
animation to go with it two electrons
move towards each other
exchange a photon and then move away
from each other again
and that's what this looks like as a
feynman diagram
in this video i'm drawing time going
upwards but some people draw it going
sideways which is quite annoying so the
first thing
you need to do when you look at a
fireman diagram is to check which way
time is going
hopefully they tell you and if they
don't then they're bad people
drawing time going upwards is the most
common way so that's what i'm doing here
okay that's the basics now let's get on
to part one of the three things we need
to know
what are the squiggly lines
these are the four kinds of lines each
corresponding to a different kind of
particle
now i can only explain this if i show
you all of the particles so here they
are these are the fundamental particles
of the universe that everything is
made of as far as we know so
far but why are they organized like this
instead of organized like this
is because some particles share similar
properties so we can group them together
kind of like my cheese collection the
straight lines represent the fermions
which are these particles these other
particles are all called
bosons now the difference between
fermions and bosons at a basic level
is the fermions make up the stuff in the
universe
and the bosons are how the stuff
interacts with each other
and they're called force carriers in
fact
everything we experience is made up of
just these three
fermions the up and down quarks which
make protons and neutrons
and when you add electrons to the
protons and neutrons you get all of the
atoms
that we're made of and everything's made
of you're made of
the bosons the force carriers are all
the other lines
we use a squiggly line for the photon
which is the force carrier for the
electromagnetic field and is the
fundamental
force mediating every single human
experience
the spiral lines are for gluons which
carry the strong force that keeps the
nucleus of atoms together
and interacts only with these specific
fermions which are called the quarks
now onto the weak force the mediators of
the weak force are the w and z bosons
and are represented with a dashed line
all particles interact with the weak
force apart from the gluons
if all this is a bit much to take in
don't worry i've made a companion poster
which you can study in your own time
the link is below so finally the higgs
boson
which we also use a dashed line for
and those are all the lines what about
gravity the fourth fundamental force
we don't use gravity here this is
particle physics
you're supposed to ask about the arrows
but what about the
arrows thanks for asking these only
appear on the solid lines of the
fermions
and they point forwards in time for mata
particles and
backwards in time for antimatter
particles
because weirdly in particle physics an
antimatter particle is exactly the same
as a matter particle it's just traveling
backwards in time
but where on my little picture are the
antimatter particles well
nobody ever bothers to draw them on the
standard model
so i've done it here here they all are
there are antimatter copies of all of
these particles which have the same mass
as the mata versions
but opposite everything else
and while we're actually drawing
actually all the particles i may as well
draw the different colour charges of the
quarks
and the eight kinds of gluons these
colors aren't real by the way just
our labeling system for keeping track of
the rules of the strong force so
um this is actually all of the
fundamental particles
goodness there's a there's a lot of
rules aren't there i'm sorry it's all
so complicated but that's just life
isn't it
so now we've covered part one and part
two what the squiggly lines mean
and what all the particles are this is
enough to be able to read feynman
diagrams and make sense of what's going
on so let's apply this knowledge with
some examples
here's one we met earlier showing two
electrons interacting with a photon and
it's an example of an interaction via
the electromagnetic force
here are a couple more but these are
interactions involving the weak force
and here's a couple involving the strong
force
you'll notice that these are all a
similar shape and i did that on purpose
because i want to talk about the
vertices
if you chop these in half you get a
vertex which is basically a meeting
point between
three particles and you can think of
these vertices as the building blocks of
a feynman diagram
you can build most feynman diagrams out
of this basis set of vertices which i'm
not going to describe in detail now but
pause the video if you want to study
them more
what is interesting about these is that
they mean different things depending on
how they are oriented
in space and time for example this is
an electron that has a change of
momentum when it emits a photon
but if i rotate it this electron becomes
a positron
remember that rule about matter
traveling backwards in time is just
antimatter traveling forwards in time
and then this shows a positron and an
electron coming together to annihilate
into a photon
so different orientations can mean very
different things
so with this basis set of vertices put
in different orientations you've got
pretty much
all you need to build any feynman
diagram
let's look at some more complicated
examples here are the electrons
interacting again but
in the middle the photon is
spontaneously turning into an electron
positron pair
before annihilating and turning into a
photon again
see if you can work out what's going on
here this is a neutron which is made of
three quarks
up down and down it decays into a proton
via the weak force
a proton is made of up down up quarks
the w boson that's emitted then decays
into an electron and an anti-electron
neutrino
so this is how neutrons can turn into
protons via the weak force
and is known in nuclear physics as beta
decay emission
this last one i'm going to leave to you
to disentangle see if you can work out
what is going on here
and specifically can you answer which
force
is mediating this interaction let me
know in the comments below what you
think
so now you know how to read feynman
diagrams congratulations
but we don't yet know how to analyze
them to see if they're valid or not
for that we need to learn the underlying
rules the particles follow
called the conservation rules of
particle physics but
to avoid information overload i'm going
to cover that in my next video
so stay tuned for that i recently
watched a great documentary on quantum
physics on magellan tv who are
sponsoring this part of the video
if you're outside of the uk you might
not know jim alkalelius he's mostly on
british tv
but he's a fantastic science
communicator and a big inspiration
to me when i started this channel and
his documentary is a brilliant summary
on the origins of quantum physics
if you want to watch it you can get it
on a free trial of magellan tv
a new streaming service founded by
filmmakers
covering science technology health
physics and many other fascinating
subjects
it's got over 3 000 documentaries so far
and new shows are being added on a
weekly basis
with a growing selection of shows
available in 4k
so if you want to check it out you can
get a one month free trial to see what
you think
at this link which you can click on in
the description below
this also helps me out because they know
you've come from here
thanks for watching and i'll see you
soon to delve deeper into this poster of
the standard model
where we'll learn the third part of
feynman diagrams where we
understand the underlying rules that the
fundamental particles follow
see you then
[Music]